hello and welcome to this video playing
hmm how Branson how come something we
don't know margin teen aren't yep so we
have an English show opening and let's
see what he is up to get it so probably
into my Roxy bind always welcome 360
games ep the bit of a rare move here not
sure there's a particular idea connected
with it no not not this time maybe
taking bishop e6 that could have been an
idea I want to play oops interesting
yeah this is possible now
didn't expect this but it's interesting
he gets something traded now I still
think what should be a little bit better
would it be six a weakness huh maybe
it's got beef I've actually me some I
have not played a free it keeps putting
stuff on g4 maybe again nigeria's what
is doing okay yeah that's absolutely
true I don't want to trade all that much
but somehow I cannot avoid it very weird
okay yeah maybe I can still try for 93 c
for something like that tween 85 maybe
27 and I so cannot play 93
hmm I think I think I go here keep you
for protected okay yes ma'am I was
rather thinking that at six but ok this
is far more logical I mean kind of
playing this in a bit of a weird way not
good at all
what's going on in um yeah not good
Quincy three problem huh wow wow getting
outplayed on the white side on the rock
see if that happens you know you have a
bad day somehow such a one sided opening
you should basically never be with but
somehow I managed so what's going on
tink OOP this ring a problem into this I
just have to be careful to equalize
maybe 93 to before no 9012 93-92 is okay
[Music]
then I think it I think it's probably
equal okay so um is f for loop where you
going to g4 f g4
[Music]
that doesn't doesn't really help
really i thought that this is a great
idea a little bit more space here okay
okay
g5 does not f5 well maybe he's got magic
spell okay okay okay okay interesting so
going to push this back ready for King
deform maybe f no five I can take 20 if
you give me space i'll take it is 50
also possible okay happy to take the
space here we go where do I get where do
I put this now to g4
hi morning not entirely sure how to
better put it I don't see that the Black
Knight is going back to d1
even if five comes into consideration
take a couple of times take with the
king I want to go to g4 feels right
check check check I'm sure there is
enough really haircut the thing look
Sally Sally nice but might not be enough
to win the game I have cake and circle
back black flip it on something if I
didn't even see that you were so so much
knock out of lower all the time and now
I did it reversed yeah it looks very
nice but it might not be a win possible
I probably spoiled some winning chances
somewhere here ok i can click on the
analysis yeah that was um yeah
absolutely nothing night she falls cause
him probably could have played an ID for
hear you Queen d2 wasn't a very
intelligent reply to a 6 a-6 is
something that they'd been Larson has
played I'm very sure bring em area sure
playing see one or something like the
engine suggests match before I'd usually
helps a little bit and it happened one
move later those traits to help I really
don't have much am I yet b5 that was
something else that was on jenni kept
playing Tai Chi for ya here I probably
have nothing when I takes off stronger
and I you know what I wanna also
underestimated is that you can go
five and he I have to fight for equality
I hope that I played it correctly at
least keeping an equal position look the
one I think made sense the King has one
I think it is just equal King jammu I
thought 263 this I mean this is also not
a problem for black but I felt like if
it just keeps looks on it it's easy m
and c 6 definitely makes sense try to
fight against myspace advantage he
didn't do anything at all I mean and
this is chan I mean I have more space he
allowed all kinds of things here give me
all that space deform yeah Here I am
getting something and probably not
playing the best I am okay so the engine
wants to free up the default square so
that 94 might happen I seen ya this is
now really know as I f5 for swimming and
the 96 Ric and see mariveles little
snippet em also makes perfect ten cent
with this knife coming yeah thing is i'm
just playing this next or hy it's cute
okay yeah still look excellent but yeah
maybe know when
and what's up fish gets like a four a
five and this is kind of hell just that
does help what if he allows that okay
that is an immediate loss not quite
seeing why probably am getting to the
pawn at the end so b6 is five kings tix
I can may I can get to be four to six at
the engine gives this and to be four it
doesn't quite see a window Jim if it
doesn't see when I deck 45 so kind of
depressing so maybe it is just a drop
okay anyway thanks for watching